hey David the Democratic primary is
heating up as you've been covering how
should we determine who is allowed to
participate in primary debates this is a
question we've been wrestling with for a
while and let's first outline what the
problems are number one if you simply
say to be in a Democratic primary for
2020 a Democratic primary debate you've
got to be polling 5% in recent polls
whatever the number you pick it's sort
of a problem to do that because if you
have no name recognition you're never
going to be initially at 5% unless you
can participate in the debates and if
you can't participate in the debates
unless you've put your polling 5% that
reinforces the status quo and it
basically allows the establishment more
gatekeeping power which I'm against so
it's a problem for me to say you got to
have 5% to participate in the primary
debates if you have no limit whatsoever
at any point you get a hundred
candidates on stage potentially or
whatever the number is 20 we saw that
when you have more than five or six the
debates become very problematic you
don't really get to hear from people in
depth about their ideas another idea is
you have to be formally on the ballot in
enough states to get 270 electoral votes
the problems there are earlier on in the
process not everyone is a lot of
candidates wouldn't yet have made those
filings so that that's a problem on the
other hand later on in the process it
may be too low of a barometer and you'd
still end up with the too many people
problem the Republicans in 2016 had this
two-tier system based on polls where you
had like the primetime debate and the
earlier debate and no one really watched
the earlier debate and that doesn't
really solve the problems in principle
it just gives you some kind of rule to
adhere to some kind of system but again
if you have 30 candidates it's not
really a solution if you were to really
take this seriously and say we don't
want to have a system that favors the
establishment what I would say is early
on very early on you do random groups of
four to six candidates if you're running
if you I think you should have to be
formally filed as a candidate you get to
participate who
you are debating the other four to five
people will be randomly assigned each
time and then as you get closer to the
election you start putting in place the
polling minimum so there's one way you
could do this for example you have the
first primary which is the Iowa caucuses
after that point you've got to have one
percent for example in three national
polls after the New Hampshire primaries
that threshold goes up you now have to
have two three four percent after the
Nevada caucuses you then have to have
five percent but up until that point you
have this random grouping of four to six
who can participate in the debates this
way you're not putting anyone out early
for not having name recognition you're
giving them a chance to be seen but
they've got to build momentum the
further into the primary process you get
once it becomes clear that they're not
going to win if we've had seven
primaries and you're not polling 3%
you're not going to win right so you can
have a sort of scale that becomes more
and more difficult it's sort of like at
the poker table you can hang out and
play without really participating in too
many hands just by betting the minimum
putting in your big blind and your small
blind but eventually those blinds are
raised such that if you've not been
winning if you've not been participating
you're gonna get pushed out just because
you can't cover the blinds anymore
that's sort of the idea other ideas I've
read about include like donor money I
don't like that that reinforces the
worst of politics we're trying to get
money out of politics and saying you
will be rewarded by being able to
participate in the bate debates if
you're raising a lot of money I don't
like that and I've not seen any other
particularly good ideas send me your
thoughts if you like my idea you don't
like my idea if you have other ideas and
we'll do a follow up about this great
bonus show for you today I'm out of time
but it's a good one get access to the
bonus show by being a member if you like
the show do the right thing
support what we're doing you don't need
to spend 200 bucks in order to make a
difference for what we're doing you
don't need to spend a hundred bucks or
90 or 80 or even 60 or 50 if you use the
coupon code this is 20/20 just three
dollars and sixty cents a month actually
moves the needle for us because of the
size of the audience and the
of people who can throw in there $3.60 a
month go to WWE at medCom
use the coupon code this is 20/20 and I
look forward to talking to you on the
members only bonus show in just a couple
of minutes